I'm G to go take another crack At
Whitman you been in there like five
times what are you gonna do annoy him
into talking haha two three
[Music]
[Applause]
4 didn't work Q did not work so again
your Alibi is a mysterious stranger
handed you the gun made you put your
prints on it robbed the store and then
and hid the gun in your underpants Well
yeah if you say it like that it don't
sound believable oh hey Captain did you
get my report on the Finley murder uh
yeah I looked it over nice work good
thanks
Dad why is everyone staring at me you
just called Captain hold dad you said
thanks Dad what no I didn't I said
thanks man do you see me as a father
figure Peralta no if anything I see you
as a bother figure cuz you're always
bothering me hey show your father some
respect I didn't call him Dad no no no
no Jacob I take it as a compliment it's
not a big deal I called Vivian mom once
and she's my fiance guys jump on that
boil has psychosexual issues old news
but you calling Hol daddy daddy is not
on the table here but you did call him
dad dude you shut up you've done nothing
but lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the hold up but
the dad thing that happened he admitted
that his Alibi was a lie it was a trap
all part of my crazy devious plan what
evidence did you have when you arrested
this guy some pretty Ironclad stuff
Destin it's been a while mind if I asked
you a few questions well well well if it
isn't joke corala that's it you're under
arrest case
closed I didn't do anything
joke that's funny you said the exact
same thing last time and have that work
out for you let's take a look okay
here's you at your
trial you in prison me meeting Regis
filin that was fun you still in prison
me at Splash Mountain just pepper these
in here you in prison you in prison you
in prison you get it you got the wrong
timey all right not ready to
confess fine by
me I got all the time in the world no
you actually have 48 hours I know the
law
nah is this about your ego are you that
desperate for everyone to know how great
you are it's not about everyone okay
it's
just I wanted you to
know oh my
God I got
it he's not answering any questions
that's okay I have no questions that's
right I'm about to monologue son better
make it quick you only got 8 minutes all
right then let me pay you a picture I'm
Philip a successful periodontist that's
become addicted to dipan a stative I
take because I'm junky scum also for
real addiction is a disease I would be
super empathetic if you hadn't murdered
a man what is the point of this I'll get
there so one day I'm working late when
my boss Robert surprises me he found out
I was stealing meds again junky scum
also again not your fault there's a
major genetic component to addiction he
says he's going to file a police report
I could lose my license we fight and
something in me just snaps so I grabb
the first thing I can find and I hit him
with it you still have no murder weapon
I do now here's a pick I found on Yelp
of the surgical suweet 6 months ago and
here is a shot that our crime scene
photographer took up the same room two
weeks after the murder notice any
differences we're not answering that
that's all right I can just tell you
myself the Yelp shot has six of these
heavy Looking Glass awards from the
Brooklyn periodontic Society in the
background whereas this shot only has
five what happened to number six you
murdered Robert with it I you lost all
control and you bludgeoned him to death
there must have been blood everywhere
but you got lucky you were in the
surgical Suite it can be sterilized you
never would have gotten away with it in
your carpeted office that's not what
happened don't say anything more Phil
and your office manager would have heard
all of the SC screaming but she was at
her grandson's play lucky again you put
Robert's body into a wheelchair and
shoved it in the elevator it's a miracle
there wasn't blood everywhere that's not
true now you're in the garage with a
corpse you panicked and left your phone
in your office and you don't have your
car keys but Roberts are in his pocket
so you put him in his car and you take
off you can't believe what you've done
you're flustered you have no GPS so you
just start driving pH next thing you
know you're in the pine Barons and it
hits you your uncle's cabin he has a
place there you're the luckiest son of a
yes it was you got lucky at every turn
no I knew exactly where I was driving I
left my phone in the office on purpose I
was in a surgical Suite by Design and I
didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see was missing I
made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it then melted
it back down it's already in a patient's
mouth
son oh damn oh damn oh damn and that is
three o dams o damn you gave him full
immunity are you insane you told me to
cut a deal I thought you'd maybe drop
charges on one or two felonies but do
you know how many crimes we're forgiving
six it's not so bad 100 oh that's way
more Grand Theft Auto Grand Theft Auto
Grand Theft Auto dog fraud I saw a guy
fake peing KN twas a cat you will not
win me over with your use of twas
twasn't trying to you're clearly friends
with this man and you've lost your
objectivity peralto or have you lost
your OB objectivity what are you doing
my bad I thought we were leaving no I'm
just making a point here sit down look
sir there's a triple murderer loose in
Brooklyn and it's our job to bring him
in even if that means forgiving a guy
who stole some cars and yes sold a few
cats as dogs more than a few weird how
many people fail for that plus his deal
is conditional if Judy doesn't lead us
to his brother he doesn't get immunity
look I want to see George behind bars as
much as you do I hate my brother you can
relate to that right sir remember how
Furious you got that time your sister
ended an email with THX instead of
thanks why would you bring that up you
seem pertinent fine let's see where this
leads dismissed all units attempted
10:30 Charlie Bodega on Smith purpose
heading East on Baltic that's us we're
on
Baltic oh crap that was him
hey and
[Music]
stop
hey
stay down damn sge maybe I do like the
stash the thug that's been terrorizing
the city say hello
Marvin hello oh my God he's so old he's
not that old his nurse isn't even
full-time he couldn't pull off a bank
job he couldn't pull off the cap on his
medicine I can hear you sorry hey this
guy is a ruthless criminal I'm sorry sir
is this going to take long cuz I was was
hoping to buy some slacks this afternoon
I like corduroy you like corduroy I love
corduroy he likes corduroy you sure you
have the right guy wasn't the robber
strong and fast and able to eat solid
foods nobody saw him eat the guy wore a
rubber mask and his voice was disguised
my system is a little unsettled could I
trouble you for ginger ale oh of course
sir we'll get that in a comfy chair for
you to sit in
yeah I Rob those Banks I don't even need
the money but I like to see the tellers
squirm I get off on violence oh my god
there you go oh thank you so much you're
such a doll I must pay you no no no I
insist I insist right here you remind me
of my granddaughter oh you are so
sweet I haven't got got a
granddaughter keep
walking let him go put that gun down or
he dies he's not going to shoot me he
needs me alive to get out of here yeah
you willing to take that bet I
wouldn't now Put the gun
down oh you shot
him are you okay I'm sorry I shot you I
thought that's what the nod meant it was
that was awesome it was actually just
like the end of speed which is a pretty
good movie it's not as good as d d okay
I'm going to go after figas yeah I was
going to say you should keep going after
figas same page
still get out of the
car young jzy Take the
Wheel freeze Punk yeah freeze Punk Jina
when did you get that gun lost and found
at the storage facility they have boxes
of them they're every everywhere so do
you recognize any of these men I was
hiding in the bathroom stall so I didn't
see his face but I heard him he was
singing along to the music at the bar do
you remember what he was singing I think
it was that song I Want It That Way
backst Street Boys I'm familiar okay
number one could you pleaseing the
opening to I Want It That Way
really
okay you
are my
fire number two keep it going the one
[Music]
desire number three
believe when I say number four I want it
that away tell me why ain't nothing but
a
heart tell me why ain't nothing but a m
now number five I never want to hear you
say I want to hear that way chills
literal chills it was number five number
five killed my brother oh my God I
forgot about that
part